Rick and Morty season seven hunting my Nemesis
maybe trying to stay healthy while doing it
juggling plates not every episode Morty could
be all happening in the background who knows
you and me Morty. Welcome back everyone it's
Charlie this will be my Rick and Morty season
6 episode 10 video there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs and references and obviously they
tease season seven so we'll break it all down if
you're brand new to the channel I will be doing
videos for all the season 7 episodes next year
when they release they will be releasing next
year careful for spoilers from this episode
if you haven't seen it yet we'll start at
the beginning just work our way through shot
by shot talking about Easter eggs WTF moments
as we go along starting with the episode title
it was called rictional Mort poons Rick Miss
mortication which is a reference to the movie
National Lampoon's Christmas Vacation mostly
because it was a Christmas themed episode where
Rick and Morty both save and ruin Christmas one
of the big differences with the episode is that
they didn't play the traditional intro sequence
I think it's probably the first time that they've
done that I don't remember previously them doing
an episode that didn't have those special intro
scenes they had a special Christmas themed title
with Christmas lights hung all over it with a
Christmas version of the theme song the opening
scene is of robot Rick as we learn programmed to
be nicer celebrating Christmas with the family
giving them all gifts that they had wanted this
whole time and that the real version of Rick had
denied them or at least in different realities
because they've been jumping realities a couple
times throughout the show but there's a joke
about that later where Morty gets the lightsaber
and Rick reveals that he's had a lightsaber
this entire time like ever since before the
events of season one Rick clanning on him saying
that he could have done this at any time the
ugly Christmas sweater that Jerry's wearing with
the deer on it also reminded me of the deer that
he and Beth almost killed the joke about the
extended extended edition of Miracle on the 34th
Street I guess as the writers think that it's a
boring movie and it's already too long but because
Jerry's so boring he loves that and wants an even
longer version I can't believe they cut all this
stuff out when they start watching the actual
movie it plays like one of Justin Royal and Dan
Harmon's fake movies from interdimensional cable
where it's meant to feel like a parody of a movie
like imagine if you asked somebody the plot of
Miracle on the 34th Street who'd never actually
seen the movie and then tried to explain that
to someone so it's just the character screaming
about different streets for a long time robot Rick
references Rick's original Beth who was killed in
his original reality in references the Clone Beth
thing again giving them the same gift like oh yeah
I guess we're doing that thing where we don't
decide who's the real one and who's the Clone
the ice cream she's eating in the picture is also
of reference to froopy land that he subsequently
created in all the other realities where Beth
did live the weird venmo joke I guess is a joke
that gen Z like Summer's generation is very tech
savvy but they also like all teenagers just want
more money so give it to me in the App instead
of giving me just like physical cash jokes aren't
summer though because I believe that venmo takes
a commission so however much money Rick gave her
they'd actually be taking a cut of that he
gives Morty a real lightsaber and they make
a ton of jokes about copyright IP George Lucas
Disney Star Wars everything Star Wars All Star
Wars jokes you could possibly make making it
sound like the Star Wars universe is just one
of the infinite universes inside the Rick and
Morty Universe like Star Wars is now canonically
part of Rick and Morty but it's like a real place
that Rick could portal to and he just stole this
lightsaber from one of the many Jedi there when he
calls Morty his number one number two that means
he's his second favorite person behind probably
bird person because there are so many Star Wars
jokes throughout the entire episode I would bet
they had to clear this with lucasfilm's lawyers
who are usually happy to allow stuff like this
within reason the only stuff that they really
put a kibosh on is like use of grogu when they
debuted grogu on the Mandalorian season 1 Dave
filoni and John Favreau said that they had to
turn down tons of requests from like all these
other media Outlets because if they let people
everybody in creation would use grogu in their
thing so they're protective of a couple things and
later in the episode when it turns into more of
a Return of the Jedi parody with the White House
and the Death Star they make a lot of the designs
look different from the actual Star Wars designs
so that it feels much more like a parody all to
protect them from getting sued out of existence
by lucasfilm's lawyers but like when Morty starts
using the lightsaber and when Rick uses his later
it makes all the exact sounds that it makes in all
the Star Wars movies and Star Wars TVs Lego
lightsaber effects are meant to be accurate
holy crap crap
elegant weapon orbit would strike me down I'll
become a pile of clothes as an Obi-Wan Kenobi
line from A New Hope when he does it but then
shows up behind the cart of fruit I think that's
meant to be a joke about The Prestige movie they
set out the actual plot of the episode when he
drops it vertically and it starts burning its way
through the core of the earth claiming that it's
going to destroy the core and destroy the planet
subsequently those are just more General jokes
about what you could theoretically cut through
with the lightsaber like everybody has that
argument like what could you actually cut through
if you had a lightsaber because one of the bits of
the episode is the president and Morty both coming
up with their own Star Wars games they played the
added benefit here is that they also use this to
reveal how many layers Rick has in his lab he has
23 but here's the thing it seems like there are
only 22 of the layers that are actually part of
this universe in the BX actually leads to a place
outside the universe or like some interdimensional
place otherwise it would just say b23 so you could
post all your theories in the comments below where
do you think the BX leads to I just feel like it
leaves it someplace outside this universe or it
leads to a place that's pure Theory like purely
concept actual idea of a place sort of like Rick
breaking the fourth wall like oh it's just another
dimension on top of this Dimension we learn he's
got a regular old sushi restaurant on level 15
that he just goes to every once in a while level
10 is where the real version of Rick is who's been
pursuing Prime rig for the past couple of episodes
ever since the Knights of the sun incident which
he references a couple of times clowning on it
saying that the whole premise was stupid like it's
the writers clowning on the previous episode we've
been to the first layer of his lab a bunch of
times it's actually pretty common the layer
below that seems like it's a botany themed plant
one and all of them seem like they're alive like
this one in the back seems like it actually has
a face below that they have all the sacks with
the people in them we've seen these sacks before
but I think the idea here is that they're either
being held prisoner because they're dangerous or
he just performing experiments on them but them
showing you the buttons to all the other levels
is just a way to tease like oh yeah we're probably
going to show some of these other levels in future
Seasons Rick makes a pretty solid Netflix burn the
joke is just that Netflix dramas are super lame
and super basic and Rick has been doing super
basic things like I've just been looking for
him this whole time there's nothing exciting
about it I just been looking for Prime rig when
the president returns he seems like he totally
knows about Star Wars Universe being a real thing
he's not surprised at all at the existence of a
real lightsaber LED that the president's secret
servicemen is a Star Wars Fanboy you know what's
in the hilt of that thing kyber crystals okay nerd
then the rest of the episode really turns into
like a Morty versus the president kind of episode
like even though Rick hates the president it was
more of a Morty versus the president episode he
makes a bunch of jokes about professional Star
Wars angry Fanboys like people who get mad at Star
Wars on social media purely for profit like Star
Wars YouTubers who only complain about Star Wars
Lucas promised a new Trilogy for decades then when
he delivered fans turned on him and started giving
any knucklehead with nerd credit shot and churned
out these irredeemable cash grabs he makes one
of the prequels he makes fun of the Disney era
of Star Wars the whole Gen X hatred reference
is about older Star Wars fans hating on younger
fans who are fans of the newer Disney era Star
Wars it'd be like you getting mad at a little
kid who likes the newer Star Wars and even though
he consoles him he continues to make fun of him
like he implies he'd rather play Star Wars games
than have sex but the joke there is that he's also
kind of clowning on himself because the President
also just wants to play Star Wars games with the
lightsaber so sort of like the writer saying that
old Star Wars fans are ridiculous and the newer
Young Star Wars fans also just as ridiculous when
he makes the joke about George Lucas's trademark
lightsaber I think that's also probably to try
and help them not get sued by lucasfilm like
yeah clearly trademarked clearly copyrighted by
lucasfilm George Lucas Rick's stuff killing people
when they touch it is a call back to season three
when he fought the president the secret surface
agent also killed automatically when he tried
to touch Rick the I Told You So technology the
Amazon Alexa burn is just that Amazon uses Alexa
to steal all your personal information and listen
to your conversations like basically spy on you
in order to earn more money off of you everybody
running around their rooms turning off all their
Alexa devices if they have them when he mentions
Randy Quaid he was actually part of the National
Lampoon's Christmas fake education Phil Spector
just a really crazy person who killed his wife
that also looks disheveled kind of like Rick
does in this episode the big drill ship going
to the planet's court is a deep impact movie
reference it's not a good movie but the ship
itself is also a giant lightsaber hilt the big
joke here is that they're just going to use one
lightsaber to destroy the second lightsaber and
then an even bigger lightsaber like the lightsaber
ship to destroy the other lightsaber when he says
he doesn't want to be neurotypical that's him
just saying that he believes that being neuro
atypical thinking in a way that's different from
most people is part of what makes him the smartest
person in the universe so thinking like everyone
else being neurotypical would be like a big step
down for him Rick having a Sith lightsaber seems
very on brand for him having a red lightsaber
they make another butter robot joke lightsaber
what's your purpose to stay vertical which they
then take back because the lightsaber itself has
this level of sentience and sassas him by taking
off and killing a bunch of people which they use
for a joke about the president being super Shady
because he blames all the Dez on Saudi Arabia
Arabia that's also meant to set up the bid at
the end of the episode where he blames the second
lightsaber accident on Morty again like ah Morty
got a lightsaber everybody sorry oh and by the
way I'm in Space the stay on target bit is a
Star Wars New Hope reference to Luke Skywalker's
Death Star Trench Run blowing up the Death Star
robot Rick's game about guessing who is a robot is
basically his desperate attempt to tell everyone
the truth without violating the programming that
will cause him to self-destruct it's also meant to
be a callback to season three with robot Morty
and robot summer wanting to exist like humans
in crying out before Rick deactivated them Rick
makes a bunch more jokes about Gene he's a regular
punching bag of the show so no big surprise there
he makes a weird David Arquette joke which I guess
is just a joke that David Arquette is super lame
and he basically reveals that he's been doing all
this stuff creating robot Rick and living like
this the past couple of episodes because Morty
basically heard his feelings by implying that he's
boring like it's all because he got his feelings
hurt Morty telling the president that he doesn't
want to have his age changed so that he can can
vote is just him saying that he hates the current
political culture war and doesn't have anything to
do with it like I am super happy to not be part
of that right now they make a joke about the
Star Wars saying May the force be with you when
the president basically turns into a version of
the emperor stealing the lightsaber from Morty
he makes another Gen X older Star Wars fan joke
about how he was raised on the original trilogy
like how he's a true fan and Morty is not because
he's a fan of the newer stuff The Muppets joke is
about the Ewoks like most Star Wars fans hated the
Ewoks when Return of the Jedi came out he makes
a bunch more Disney Star Wars jokes transform
and roll out is also a Transformers joke another
big 80s franchise I literally just did a trailer
video for Transformers rise of the Beast which is
basically a beast Awards movie I'll put a link for
that in the description below because it actually
looks pretty decent Transformers movies looking
up now that they got rid of Michael Bay then
marching out in formation is a reference to the
Empire just part of the idea that the president
is turning into a version of the emperor at the
end of the episode The Family turns on robot Rick
in a montage using the first Nobel all Christmas
song which they use later in the episode too they
use his Parts as Christmas ornaments then during
the Montage as the president plays with Morty's
lightsaber he also drops it again doing the exact
same thing that Morty did Jerry has a long dark
night of the Soul kind of moment when he asks
summer for drugs like summer do you have anything
on you right now and they continue with the whole
idea of the president turning into a dirt bag
because he basically escaped to space in the White
House like he had the secret Escape Plan Michael
you'll all be destroyed but not me the whole thing
with prime rake showing up all over the Multiverse
is his way of spoofing his signal so that it seems
like he's in every single Universe it's just a way
to show you how he is one step ahead of Rick like
it'll take him a lot more work to actually find
him during season seven that's part of the big
teaser at the end of the episode part of his new
rant 100 Years of Rick and Morty looking for Prime
Rick even though the White House is meant to be
a parody of the Death Star now his office layout
here is actually a reference to Cisco's office in
Star Trek Deep Space Nine he also implies that he
doesn't know how to cook a simple egg like he's
that dumb Morty cutting through the door with the
lightsaber is a phantom menace reference remember
the whole idea here is the president hated the
prequels making fun of them along with the new
Trilogy so this is meant to be another dig at him
like an older Star Wars fan being clowned on some
of you may have detected the Mr P reference as a
super deep cut because the rapper Mr P actually
interviewed George Lucas 20 years ago to try and
get him to make a quote-unquote ghetto Star Wars
version somebody told me you already have five
episodes already done already well I've got one
more to write and all of these were written 30
years ago your journey is now complete as one of
the emperor's lines from Return of the Jedi and
this scene is also meant to play out like a Return
of the Jedi parody with him confronting him on the
Death Star they're taking a lot of shots of Star
Wars fans the US president like they're saying the
whole White House is the Death Star Morty grabbing
robot Rick before he tries to kill himself in the
door is an Indiana Jones Temple of Doom joke with
him saving his hat at the last minute they've also
used that joke in subsequent Indiana Jones films
as well then making more Luke lucasfilm General
jokes during the episode just because so much of
it is a lucasfilm Star Wars joke they revealed
the president has a whole ass Fanboy room full of
Star Wars memorabilia and replicas made to look
like the emperor's throne room in the Death Star
a lot of it is actually working technology too
because remember the whole idea is that the Star
Wars universe is real inside the Rick and Morty
Multiverse even though to avoid copyright being
sued by a lucasfilm they made some of these look
like parodies but they're meant to look close to
versions from Star Wars like he's got a version
of a Cantina he's got replicas of the Death Star
Trench Run scale size some of the robots are made
to look different for copyright reasons like
I said but these are meant to be battle droids
he's got an R5 unit you can let me know who you
think this is frozen in carbonite he's got a tie
Advanced a regular TIE fighter there's an atst
all the banners on the upper level are meant to
be parody versions of the Imperial banners 2 but
change for copyright reasons and he claims that
Jimmy Carter built it when he was in office
because he was president when the first Star
Wars movie A New Hope was released Ronald Reagan
tried to destroy it when he took office George W
bush added kegs you can guess what the other U.S
presidents did to it when they took office like
he doesn't talk about George senior he doesn't
talk about Bill Clinton it always felt like the
Keith David president was meant to be a version of
Obama so I don't know if Obama was also president
in this reality or the Rick and Morty Multiverse
or if he's just meant to beat the version of Obama
because within Rick and Morty Canon he's meant
to be a different person like his name is not
the same as Obama's name the droys he releases
on them are real they're meant to be versions
of the pit droids from Phantom Menace they've also
featured those during the Mandalorian later in the
timeline they give Morty a big lightsaber battle
the robots with too many lightsabers are a General
Grievous joke the president makes a bunch more
Disney Star Wars jokes and the joke about the poor
CGI and the Disney plus Star Wars shows I think
is meant to be a book of Boba Fett joke but also
a joke on a lot of the Marvel Disney plus series
the one big green screen that he starts talking
about is called the volume it's technically not a
green screen it's a different type of Technology
Dave filoni and John Favreau have talked a lot
about it in their behind the scenes featurettes
the lightsaber Gatling gun seems like a Nerf gun
joke like it actually looks kind of like a real
Nerf gun they pay off the vertical lightsaber bit
again when the tiny ones pass through robot Rick's
body destroying the White House and playing the
same song as before real Rick saves them but the
dramatic speech that robot Rick has is meant to
be a reference to Darth Vader's death on the Death
Star then they make up and he starts helping him
find and kill Prime brick like he basically says
he's going to join his mission which they say will
happen during season seven in him ranting about
finding prime rig is a callback to all of his
rants in previous Seasons like his new rant 100
years Rick and Morty new Szechuan sauce rant is
all about finding prime Rick during season seven
also meant to be their official teaser for Rick
and Morty season 7 which they'll probably spend
more episodes actually hunting Prime rig but the
rest of the rant is also similar to season 4 when
they came back from the break and he ranted about
not every episode being part of the overarching
story like sometimes there'll be one-offs so
this is their way of saying that oh like the
prime rig story will continue in a much bigger
way during season 5 but not every single episode
then in the post-credits scene they have a big
call back to season two when they bring back Mr
Poopy butthole who's watching the episode like
he was in the season 2 post-credits scene but
he also references the events of his previous
post-credit scenes where he lost his family
they basically left him apparently he's been
getting super ripped since he lost his family
his trainer Carl is a reference to Dan Harmon's
real life assistant who's helped him with his
workouts sometimes like if you follow Dan Harmon
on social media during the pandemic in particular
he was actually doing a bunch of workouts and
streaming them on his social media accounts so Mr
Poopy butthole doing a bunch of workouts is like
a big Dan Harmon joke he breaks his legs and they
have a bunch more jokes about his ex-wife or maybe
they're just separated blocking his number I guess
the joke there is that he just spent so much time
harassing her or calling her on the phone that she
had to block his number and I believe they plan
to release season 7 episodes around the same time
next year maybe a little bit earlier in the summer
but close to the same time I'll do a video as soon
as they release an official teaser or a trailer
video but if you spotted any other Easter eggs or
references or Star Wars jokes in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video just
write them Below in the comments one of the
other notable things in the episode is that
space Beth was there for the entire episode for
Christmas for the family's Christmas but didn't
really actually contribute that much to the
episode like she was just there hanging out
normally when spacebest shows up you would expect
her to do something but this season they've kind
of had that bit going on all season long where
she just shows up and sits around everyone click
here for all my Rick and Morty episodes and click
here for my new Joker 2 first look teaser video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!